vous savez, j'aimerais certainement que l'
industrie du divertissement considère des
histoires sur toutes sortes de personnes, je
soupçonne que ces chiffres vont
changer parce que plus nous parlons de
femmes en position de prendre des
décisions et de créer et produire et de
donner le feu vert à des films et même à la télévision
énorme  quantité de grands rôles à la télévision
pour les femmes, je pense qu'il serait difficile de se
retirer de cette destination que
cette ambition, je pense que nous avons tous de
grandes conversations sur la diversité et
l'égalité, mais aussi dans la façon dont nous
produisons des histoires et à qui nous racontons
des histoires pour et sur et plus souvent
qu'autrement ces derniers temps,
nous voyons des films dans des salles de cinéma
avec des femmes qui se débrouillent
très bien, il est difficile de nier qu'il y a
un public, vous savez, 50% de notre
population dans notre pays est
essentiellement féminine dans  termes de l'ensemble de l'
industrie si vous pensez que vous connaissez
tout le monde sur un plateau le mixeur du département du son
a raison les concepteurs de production la
post-production  les caméramans de travail, nous
voulons que les femmes se sentent remplies et et et nous
voulons que la diversité remplisse tous ces rôles de
comptabilité, vous savez, le service d'artisanat, mais
s'ils n'ont pas été autorisés et qu'il y a une
sorte d'apprentissage, je pense que le
pipeline, je pense, va  prendre plus
légitimement plus de temps, mais je pense que
travailler vers 5050 est très
admirable et je pense que nous y arriverons,
je ne sais pas si ce sera d'
ici 2020